Oh welcome the fat man our Batman I'm
Kevin Smith hi I'm Mark Bernard we have
no better opening for the show yeah just
kind of having that way we keep going
with it OPP yeah
welcome welcome ladies and gentlemen to
the scum and villainy Cantina right here
on Hollywood Boulevard in the heart of
Hollywood put your hands together so the
folks at home know that you are real I
feel great I've been as of today I'm
down 30 pounds from the heart attack and
I don't know it's weird I don't miss
food I've got this different
relationship with food now now I'm like
one of those people that like you know
now I see conspiracy and everything I'm
like that's how the food people get you
know but it's been an interesting run
and so far so [ __ ] good I traveled
for the first time to do a gig this
weekend I went to Vancouver British
Columbia where we do flash and Supergirl
while they do it I just show up from
time to time and stuff arrows of their
legends and they have a whole you know
country Canada so one up there to do two
gigs for the Rio theater which is an art
house bless you that's closed that was
close to closing down and they were able
to kind of buy themselves more time and
stuff like that so I did two shows we
raised like 50 grand for the for their
fund they still got a ways to [ __ ] go
and stuff like that but Ryan Reynolds
who is a local he tweeted about it so I
guess that was nice I felt like saying
hey [ __ ] I had a heart attack and
[ __ ] flew up there did two shows and
I ain't even [ __ ] from Vancouver man
you got that Deadpool money get your
[ __ ] ass up there be Canadian
I was lovely the wonderful [ __ ] gig
he did put out a tweet actually until
that's people who donate and they did
like 20 grand or something like that
they pulled in just from him
highlighting it which is very nice but
the shows were [ __ ] fun and I the big
concern of course from the family was
like oh my god you're gonna die on the
plane but you know because the heart
attack but I was like that was always
true like you know always a pretty high
chance that I wasn't coming back but
thanks for the new concern and it went
fairly well and then I came home and
then I've been editing but working on
this 'edit for this movie that we've
been shooting in Sarasota Florida kill
Royce here at horror movie plays like
[ __ ] Creepshow so much so that I'm
temp music creep shows the temp score as
I'm cutting and stuff and you fall down
a [ __ ] rabbit hole when you start
putting the [ __ ] together like I lost
two days just in the editing room and
stuff but so far so good I'm liking what
we're doing we still have two more
sequences to shoot I think we do that in
June we go back to Florida and shoot
again where my kid pointed out I
probably had a mild heart attack and
didn't even know it last time we were
out there shooting one night I
complained of like not chest pains with
the same thing where I was this I can't
quite catch my breath and I feel like I
got a lot of mucus maybe I smoked too
much weed that's what I always pinned it
up I always pinned it out and like I'm
no doctor but I'm like let me imagine
inside my body what it feels like is
there's a lot of mucus because I smoked
too much weed what it was was probably
at that point 95% blockage in that
[ __ ] artery had nothing to do with
weed whatsoever so that I remember
shooting that night she told me after I
had the heart attack she was like this
that you had the same kind of pain in
Florida and I remember going like oh man
give me some crackers and she's like why
and I was like because I got this thing
here where if I chew it'll roto-rooter
the [ __ ] mucus down and stuff that's
how I was gonna cure a [ __ ] heart
attack with the [ __ ] goddamn pack of
saltines so I and then I said she said
in the weirdest thing as you went and
lay it down which you know I guess isn't
weird on a movie set I do that all the
time but like the idea of going to sleep
when you're in the midst
a cardiac a cardiac episode but I didn't
realize that was a cardiac episode now I
know what it is and stuff so next time I
go back to Sarasota no [ __ ] mild
heart attacks either and then we'll
finish the movie and come back I mean
let's just sleep they will they will but
you know [ __ ] on a movie set you're
not supposed to you're supposed to be
directing and I was just like I'm gonna
take a nap you guys got this like just
look out don't curse to my I [ __ ]
curse all you want goodnight I remember
hearing the story about David Milch when
he was working on Deadwood hmm and in
the they were shooting the way he would
write he would write out of sequence he
would write to what they would shoot the
next day so every episode he's just
literally writing the scenes out of
order finished us together and one day
his back went out so he's laying on the
floor of his office shouting up words
that the assistant is supposed to type
they're gonna ferry those words to the
stage so they can shoot so he's prone on
his back writing and they're just all
right david says we're gonna do this now
okay Tim the elephant's ready to go here
you you could direct from your back even
with your eyes closed is that the point
of that milk story the point in that
story is I was like what an inspiring
story about a man who I gaze back one
out but he's still at the [ __ ] work I
guess but now I see the parallel that
you were man I'm just saying verticality
is not a prerequisite for getting the
work done that's true being vertical is
[ __ ] overrated my mom is still in
town adorable was last week with your
mind oh she loved it she could not have
got enough what were your big hero when
she left here like Mark they love you
god bless you like what she blowing you
up she was home I mean yeah a little bit
and she said that you know cuz she was
in the house for a little bit after the
fact that she's a couple people we love
your son your son is so smart and I said
yeah I am
you just never say that mom you need
strangers to tell you that I'm smart
what the [ __ ] she's the guy I had a
confirmed by some
Angelenos yeah she had a lovely time
she's still in town so I've been like
tour guide what he been doing what do
you show how old your mom mallamma 76
years old show a 76 year old woman in
Los Angeles that will even impress her
that she'd even be like oh my god I gave
birth yes this is [ __ ] I took it to
the to the sky space in downtown LA when
you go to the top of the US bank
building the tallest building in
downtown LA they have an observation
deck up there and a [ __ ] glass slide
have you heard about this glass slide
they have in their own we're from the
76th floor you can get him a glass slide
on the exterior of the building that
goes in the 76th floor the 75th floor
you're literally sliding over downtown
LA on a glass slide I'm a glass slide
that's the part of it that I'm having a
hard time with well I mean I'm in it for
the inheritance so feel like you go
first yeah bad mom it's great
[Applause]
wow that sounds interesting
so did you did your mom do is she
totally [ __ ] banished took the slide
yeah I didn't know when she goes home
she's gonna tell people that story I was
on a glass sliding board can you believe
that about Los Angeles what a [ __ ] up
city did you believe my son pushed me
down a glass that part of the story
they'll believe yeah I went down to
Rancho Palos Verdes which is about an
hour south of here I know it's very
fancy
what's the Rancho port it's in the way
that you went to Palos Verdes we went
for a minute I was like wow you go to
the fancy fellow's baby okay
I took her last night to the Magic
Castle Oh once but they didn't let me in
because I wasn't wearing a suit I was
wearing shorts and they were like you
can't come in like this I was like I go
everywhere dressed like this and they
said you need a suit no it was just like
you need a guy to fill my seat goodbye
so my wife forget have been there many
times they [ __ ] love it yeah how was
it it's super fun it's pricey though
they'll hit you walking in there
they hit you at the door the hitch of
the valet they hit you in dinner they
hit you
but there's also [ __ ] magic which is
really kind of lovely sounds like
Disneyland Ghana is and like watching my
76 year old mom try and puzzle out these
tricks just eventually come to it must
be [ __ ] magic mama swear dollars not
magic as pros who do it every night or
plying their [ __ ] trade your mama
just like I see strings yeah no that's
[ __ ] or he really limit ated that
lady like mom I swear to god he didn't
do that he's got power
aren't you bringing kids as well no cuz
they don't look kids in after dark
oh really yeah it's adult magic its
adult well it's not a dog they just
don't want kids they're you know get my
kid to wear a suit little rough I mean
getting an adult to wear suits little
rough too I wasn't I was like you
realize I could walk into Denny's dress
like this that place is magical as well
I wonder if they would [ __ ] with you if
you had the the Jersey crest with it
tucks look the tie and the lapels oh
yeah this count here's my way
[ __ ] like you've realized
they've had tuxedo t-shirts for 30 years
get the [ __ ] off the property you've
recommended that was the magic good I
would it was really good especially the
close-up magic when you were literally
like feet away from I do doing card
tricks and coin tricks and like little
[ __ ] three-card Monte [ __ ] where it's
oh you just practice this for decades
you're just really good at doing [ __ ]
like his hands were all [ __ ] weird
because they've been bending awkwardly
since like I mean it's like was that
part of his actors there's something
like you just sort of like oh hey look
I'm doing the [ __ ] quarter I'm in the
back of my hands oh you're one of those
judgy hand people man that makes people
like Trump nervous look at those [ __ ]
hands
you can't hold a peach with your tiny
tiny hands I try to hide my feet all the
time for that [ __ ] reason people look
at your feet and should be like nine and
a half not big I'm like nowhere but if
you could do magic with your feet you
would show every [ __ ] your feet
oh [ __ ]
you should become a magician that should
be your catchphrase you got that's a
little [ __ ] I got I had to I had to form
a company I had to incorporate why this
week I've did that many years ago you
did because you were making movies and
like making real money I know they
forced me to do it I have never done
that before
but yeah there's a there's a couple of
like super fancy Hollywood things in
motion and like well if you don't want
to have to pay taxes on this [ __ ] you
need to incorporate really I get to make
it company sure who's in it you all
right anybody else no just you company
of one but I get to name a company which
is fun what's your name it uh well I
went on the Twitter's and I asked for
suggestions like what should I name a
company and lots of people like Deez
Nuts you like thank you I'll come up
with my own yeah I was like what sure
I'm in my fancy has company they're like
fancy has company I'm like yeah they're
not gonna let me do that though a lot of
people like Bernard Inc like Bernard oh
[ __ ] that's is yeah I didn't do that
though no it was cute though it was good
I was down to two choices I was down to
Bernard and aerospace and plumbing
that's good which I thought was kind of
Phyllis gray and then dazzling urbanite
Inc and I went with dazzling urbanite
because I am a dazzling urbanite very
nosy right
somebody's girl agrees with me I think
everyone was leaning toward the
astronautical one I think you should
keep Bernarda ink in your back party
that's a good little logo started with a
giant see at the end of it just comes
marching in like the Pixar lamp
[Applause]
can you see about CC that well that you
could still have as your production
company name this is just your
incorporated name right what you do
business under yes I have been what have
I been well view excuse the brush should
come ago we also incorporated vsq
snowgoons Inc I've been that for a long
long time remember Jason Mewes was like
you took my word and made it a business
but I wrote that word it's my work I did
it I was like you may have said it a lot
but I actually wrote it into a script so
ownership is nine-tenths of the law
well welcome to the world of [ __ ]
high international business my fur I
can't wait they'll give you one of them
certificates stock certificates as your
name on it I have mine framed a long
time ago and hung in the office I'm so
proud I was like holy [ __ ]
we're legitimate and they sent the tax
bills and I was a call.we [ __ ] I wish we
were illegitimate because they're zipped
us away can I do under the table ink
it's you that have been it just gave me
under the table guarantee you get
audited every year all right we got news
we have some news ladies and gentlemen
we're about to get this [ __ ]
started in earnest
we start Fatman on Batman by getting
into something we call the utility belt
which covers all the news that's either
fit to print or mark printed up so let's
dive into it with news master mark
Bernard give it up for him ladies and
gentlemen but before the news begins
look at this
what's my girlfriend's birthday her name
is Jennifer where's Jennifer happy
birthday man I won't give it up for
Jennifer she's alive she'll be singing a
song for just give her a song because
Warner Brothers don't own it anymore man
three one two three birthday to you
happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear
happy birthday
[Applause]
and that's the news right on all right
that takes us into the newsman happy
birthday happy birthday you're so
welcome you are so getting blown tonight
right when you come think of us just
everywhere they go when we were kids
like we would go eat at this restaurant
called mr. steak which was in Shrewsbury
you know she was very from back home a
marker from both in the same neck of
well you live there later on I did
you're not from there but you're like
yeah yeah so he knows where I'm from and
in any event they had a restaurant
called mr. steak and back in those days
I'm talking like the 70s to the early
80s if you just walked into a restaurant
and said oh it's my birthday they
brought you a free [ __ ] cake and we
ate at mr. steak because it was like a
really kind of I loved it but you know
with I've always talked fallen layabout
up my brother's like you know that was a
low-end meat joint right but it was they
had a cow that was smiling on the
[ __ ] thing and the birthday thing was
cool every time we went to meet at mr.
steak was at least twice a week man
because they had a special my mom cut
out of the paper all the time we went in
my mom would be like it's this one's
birthday it's that one's birthday and
finally they had to change the [ __ ]
policy after a long time because they're
like these kids man how many birthdays
they got my mom's like they used to be
Jehovah's Witness so they're catching up
they want all their birthday back now
well you guys been on the grift did you
know I knew that my mom was up to no
good because she sent us to Catholic
school and I was a [ __ ] altar boy but
at the same time I like cake mark so you
know hate the sin love the sinner when I
was like six years old I remember going
on my first plane ride with my folks and
this was back in the 70s when I think if
you were under five you could fly for
free oh [ __ ] yeah and so I was five
years old until I was nine years
but I did like early on in this grift I
didn't know so my best how old are the
children you would say well this one's
five and this one's two and I'd say no
I'm Savin shut the [ __ ] up
do you have $185 in your body meanwhile
[ __ ] aged 13 you got peach fuzz
coming in how old are you five
all right man so let's dive into the
news what's happening this week in the
world of entertainment I feel like we're
in a [ __ ] vacuum for the next
twenty-one days until or 24 days and so
how many date what's today the third so
24 days until Avengers hits and you know
chances are yes god yes
chances are thanks to our various
connections and the business of show we
might actually get to see it a little
earlier than that too we might accept
they just Thanos sent a letter
apparently which is like I'm coming
destiny is coming I'm like I know [ __ ]
I saw the trailer a thousand but Fano
sent a letter that the Russo brothers
delivered saying that they are not
screening the movie in its entirety
until the premiere which is going to be
the Tuesday of opening week all right so
what's that date so then the - that
would be the 23rd for 24 math sure so
the press won't get to see it like I I
might actually get to cover the junket
for The Avengers movie because I think
why because sci-fi wants me to interview
Kevin Feige
oh and also get me a [ __ ] movie -
right but the press won't get like I'll
have to interview him without having
seen the movie because they won't show
it to press going to the junket they're
very very [ __ ] concerned about
spoilers leaking out so something
drastic happened I think
a story this week where the Russo
brothers indicated that the title of
Avengers 4 is a spoiler may include some
stuff that refers to what happens in
infinity war Avengers 4 caps did right
yeah
that's the name of that song yes Oh
captain my captain standing on desk
seating shwarma all right so the Russo
brothers yeah yeah I've said that
they're not gonna show they are not even
at the premiere that's whenever the
premier will be the first time than
anybody sees and then everybody has to
keep their mouths shut right
who and they won't look yeah I'm sure
they'll be like slugworth in the corners
like hey kid maybe if you tell me what
happened I'll give you all the [ __ ]
money in the world what a great poll man
like the slugworth of it all but he
worked for Willy Wonka he did he did so
in this case slugworth would be somebody
who takes you right to Kevin Feige
pretty much like I was supposed to
interview he's like not anymore the
slugworth talking [ __ ] you were
a fan of the stranger things right uh
yes of course who was well made [ __ ]
television did anybody else in here like
the stranger things coming soon isn't it
part 343 there shows you what a huge fan
of part three is I think they're
starting production pretty soon but the
duffer brothers just got slapped with a
lawsuit well yeah what no stop making
[ __ ] people like it turns out that at
the Tribeca Film Festival in 2014 a
felon named Charlie Kessler met with the
the the duffer Brothers and said hey you
know what I made a short film called
Montauk which is kind of about a bunch
of kids and like rural America for us it
was like the deep end of Long Island but
and they're living next to some
government facility and weird
supernatural [ __ ] happens in this town
and the death of brothers allegedly
we're like that's awesome we're working
on something similar and I don't think
they said that though
yeah so then when strange things the
first season was in like the beginning
of production they hadn't settled on
untitled yet it was called the Montauk
Project the [ __ ] there is yeah and so
now this dude is suing them saying that
the duffer brothers stole his idea which
there is a trailer like a short film
that he shot which is that thing there's
a featured screenplay that he wrote
which is that thing and it says that
picture to another party and we had a
verbal agreement that they reneged on
and so now I want all the money Wow yeah
now I think the chances are slim despite
that I mean the most damning thing is
the fact that they called stranger
things Montauk for like a year yeah but
there is no real proof of that agreement
because it becomes a he-said she-said
right and it'll get settled out of court
is my guess because the duffer's don't
want to go to trial and also netflix has
all the money right so this dude is
suing for a piece of the profits and to
stop production so they can be made
whole and executive producer credit in
the whole shebang like he just wants his
piece of what he thinks is his he will
never get it he will just get a pile of
money and be told to go home happy
because that's the way this [ __ ] happens
right you know it is incredibly hard to
prove that you have been ripped off but
it's also incredibly ugly and loud and
long to go to trial that's why I make
unwatchable movies
no one else in the world is gonna be
like a man I wrote tusks believe me I've
tried I've paid people to say it it
doesn't [ __ ] work yeah that's kind of
a [ __ ] bummer man I guess somebody
could like sue me for stealing their
[ __ ] and that would be Jason Mewes yeah
half of Jay and Silent Bob's literally
predicated on who he was when he was 16
but he's been in on and stuff so I guess
he won't sue me at the end of the day
these cats though if you're gonna sue
anybody [ __ ] man sue Netflix they got a
nickel I'm not saying let's all do it
but if this guy has a claim and [ __ ]
sounds that sounds more than
circumstantial no it does but I'm not
saying that they were like hey we're
gonna deal with you and then [ __ ] off
but you know he's got something that
tells C smells like it or something like
that that's a shame
is a shame because it's like crazy
original it's crazy original and totally
derivative at the same time and that
it's oh my god every [ __ ] Spielberg
movie it's every you know John Carpenter
movie it's every Stephen King novel just
put in a blender and spit out with epic
organs right in that way it's kind of
like like one of my favorite aspects of
the work of Quentin Tarantino is the
same thing it was like a pop culture
blender that goes back a couple decades
and stuff and so you're seeing something
new but you're always seeing it push
through a prism of things that he's seen
and stuff it's it's hip-hop filmmaking
ultimately oh my god you're right you
know sampling it simply gets let me take
these components of other [ __ ] that
you've heard of before and put it
together in a way that you never would
have thought of and then it becomes
something entirely new in the process
holy [ __ ] man that's clever
all right so steal that [ __ ] or I will
come no no no no I can write it did I
see an article this week about you like
in sci-fi were you on a podcast or
something I was yeah I wrote a lovely
[ __ ] write-up for you where they they
[ __ ] blew you and then in the fifth
paragraph they were like he also hosts
co-hosts hot
with the likes of Kevin Smith so it was
really nice I know there was the dude
the features editor at sci-fi wire that
I occasionally write for also has a
podcast there's like do you want to do
the podcast I'm like I'm okay at doing
podcast sure I can do that and that's
true and so I talked to the do for like
an hour and a half and it was one of
those tell me your story obi-wan Kenobi
and I'm like but sure I can [ __ ] for
a while hmm
and and just like soup to nuts where you
came from how you got here what you're
doing now what do you think about ABCD
and E and it was a really sweet kind of
conversation and then they wrote what is
essentially like a eulogy for me in this
piece that's what it felt like I was
like oh [ __ ] either mark barnard and
died or okay or mark two or something
like that that's kind of it looked like
they were saying goodbye to you know
it's very sweet and of course I blew up
the podcast because I don't forget the
girl who brung me what you brought your
mom to the bike oh oh I thought that's
what you said I said you don't forget
the girl who brung you in that lawyer
you brought me up on the buggy yeah I
thought you're saying you brought your
mom with hills like that's adorable did
she just go with you everywhere you
watch since we set the car into a
podcast did you you plug this good I did
yeah we could always use the [ __ ]
house all right so what next ready play
one made some money ready player one
opened we got to see it early man so I
wasn't really following the box office
but I imagined it was number one it was
number one it did pretty well it made
fifty three million dollars domestic oh
and they were saying like low 40s or
something in the beginning of the week
going like oh it's gonna be the highest
grossing Spielberg opening in a while
but not record-breaking so it did a few
more bucks
it did a few more bucks they added in
the Thursday because it opened Thursday
for Easter weekend and it Dupree well
internationally 181 million dollars
globally which ain't bad
no really often again brand-new IP with
like lots of existing IP as flavor all
over it but right you know it's it's not
it's based on a book that not everybody
knows in our community people sure know
it but I think those sound like pretty
decent numbers it's certainly not
Avengers country but like who is know I
mean they're pretty decent numbers
especially what was it I think it has a
higher second week it could could
absolutely do that that's insanely rare
but like especially what was its opening
Wow 53 53 million yeah Wow that'd be
that would be incredible if it had a
higher second week but it doesn't it
really does that but I mean the movie
that was the most surprising this this
winter was the greatest showman did you
ever catch up with that I have an Oscar
screener that I get to watch I hope to
vote for it later on it opened it 7.9
million dollars okay and it was in the
top ten for 25 weeks really I think yeah
like it kept making money it made and
ultimately topped out at a hundred and
eighty million dollars [ __ ] me
just if you make eight million dollars a
week for 20 weeks and nobody doesn't go
I mean nobody stops going right it's
it's like they were they were comparing
it to Titanic in that it didn't open
that huge but the staying power of Hugh
Jackman is impressive was consistent Wow
and it's the la-la-land kids right there
right there were songs in the soundtrack
and it you know the [ __ ] me mobile
nature of it all I don't think ready
player one is gonna do quite that I
don't think it's gonna make like thirty
million dollars for the next eight weeks
but it's got a shot to still be in the
conversation until the ventures open
what was the general reaction from the
people in the press and stuff that
people liked it I know in advance they
were they were worried for some reason
at one point that's be a Burt kid I
don't know if he's guys yeah he's so
unproven the response was divided I
think there were there were some people
who loved it some people who totally
swung with the pop culture overload of
it all some people who felt it was a
little bit sad in that so much of the
movie is about looking backwards that
are forward so much of it is Herman
sealed within itself so much of it is
about the things already Klein loved
when he was a kid and but technically
the whole movie is set in the future so
it's all looking forward true true
did you not dig it were you guys divided
over the flick yeah boo arms over there
I I stole I liked it and I still liked
it I think it's a fun flick and I think
it's nice to see that dude you know
playing in the playground that he
[ __ ] built nobody makes these
blockbuster ridiculous movies word now
for Steven Spielberg doing it with jaws
first and strike and rich so his you
know and then think about he do directed
our childhoods he directed all the
movies that made people who make movies
today ever think about making movies in
the first place because of so it's nice
to see him out there still [ __ ] doing
it I thought the movie was really cool I
had a good time at a smile on my face
the whole time but that number sounds
like right I don't think that's
scandalous I don't think it like it's
not like you know it seems like it seems
like it'll easily get to a hundred or
more I don't know what a cost will cost
one seventy-five really yeah cuz it
looked a lot more expensive than that
apparently needs to make between 600 and
650 global to break-even six hundred
million global in that's like that's the
you know what Wonder Woman do 700 780
and that was kind of a global phenomena
that was a thing well it'll do well I'm
doubtful every it's not like they're
like we'll help me stir Spielberg
you're done leave Hollywood directors
jail for you something tells me he'll be
back yeah the one sounds like he's doing
well that's good money the one damning
statistic was that this movie opened at
51 million dollars power rangers opened
at forty two million dollars how much
was this 53 and power rangers was 42
yeah so what's the lesson here we need
to reconsider the power
I think the lesson was as exhibitor
relations the sort of box of supporting
company was like this is not a massive
hit given who it's coming from given
what we're playing with because Power
Rangers did almost as well I know but
that is the weird [ __ ] internal you
know I think fair to judge the dude
against his previous [ __ ] work you
got to remember like you that he created
classic adventure cinema that while in a
time that like it wasn't happening eight
times a weekend and twenty-eight times a
day on your channel or [ __ ] streaming
device and whatnot it's a lot that he
was you know the only guy out there at a
time with all the talent in the world
telling those kinds of stories now other
people get to tell big stories and stuff
like that but doesn't mean that like
everything he has to do who has to
[ __ ] bring the same like two hundred
five hundred million dollar bail that's
what I tell myself when I wake up every
morning you don't ever have to be as
good as your hold of work we love you
just the way you are I yeah it didn't
like beyond us going to see it and
they'd opening and whatnot it didn't
come back on my radar I didn't see
anything on social media nobody slamming
it or anything like that's a good sign
yeah I saw he said some things at one
point where people like hey man yeah he
was like I don't believe that a movie
that's been on Netflix should ever be
eligible for an Oscar we've got all
Chris Dolman about yeah he got he got
super 73 year old guy on it did look man
baby to me in the big screen are
supposed to be a star the movie number
one his 73 is been doing it longer than
any of us seen stuff and practically
invented a genre by himself so he's
definitely allowed to like of course say
what he thinks but you know that just
felt like tilting against who knows at
this point it's like that's that's where
all the movies are eventually gonna be
dude yeah you wait Steven
don't threaten our greatest American
homemaker I'm just saying what he wants
to make Lincoln to electric bugaloo
you know what he's going that's on
[ __ ] Netflix that'd be great if
Daniel day-lewis is like I will come out
of retirement what what happens next in
the world of genre and comics and all
the good things that make us happy in
life do you know the CW has some comic
book shows on it I've heard did they all
get renewed they all how did you [ __ ]
know cuz man that's I came here to grab
yeah I know I was but it's also my
goddamn job
Thank You tree news who at work next
year yeah the flash goes to season five
arrow goes to season 28 Supergirl goes
to I pick season motors there is now
four one two yeah they go to season four
and legends goes to four also host of
four and Black Lightning goes to two oh
right on
so all the DC shows and Riverdale also
got Riverdale the the only one that is
currently on the bubble DC wise is
iZombie but they always renew that later
they tell that's a midseason [ __ ] yeah
they've all moved out in May and stuff
so there's a good chance that's coming
back as well
[ __ ] dude that's what you and me need to
do is get a goddamn show on the CW
because they don't cancel nothing nope
oh my god supernatural has been on the
air literally for 96 years those two
boys have an age to [ __ ] day do you
know those two kids have fun kids I mean
they're probably [ __ ] older than us
at this point but like the two kids who
are on supernatural bought a [ __ ]
their own jet off of working on that
show Wow
their own [ __ ] jet dude like to go
where that's they're always making
supernatural I have exactly the same
[ __ ] Vancouver all the time though
like we use it as our trailer that's
like I've known rich people in my life I
don't know anybody owns a [ __ ] jet
[ __ ] jet that's supernatural money
whoo we missed the boat there I mean
nobody asked us but still what no it's
not some day though Saiga constant she's
coming to Legends so don't give me a
[ __ ] jet though yes Constantine
coming alleges we talked about that we
did welcome to last week [ __ ]
okay all right well yes all those shows
being renewed is fabulous news
for me personally as a TV viewer those
are my stories I like them and for two
of them fun for me because I get to go
back and hopefully work on them again oh
yeah it's good time my flash episode
airs
April 10th I think it is it's coming up
its next week yeah it's a week from
today
so the next flash episode is the one I
directed fun what happens we meet we
meet I'll tell you what the problem
presents itself and the boy solves it by
running super [ __ ] fast spoilers all
right what else we got
are you a fantastic four fan yeah of
course I I mean I'm not so much a fan
like all [ __ ] you know I [ __ ] blow
Reed Richards but I love the I have deep
respect for them as Marvel's first
family as we all know that's the
Stanley's told the story many times he's
about to quit Marvel he's doing all
funny animal comic comics and like
parody comics and romance comics and
nurse comics all these kinds of comics
and stuff I didn't want to work for
Martin Goodman any more timely comics is
what it was called then and so Joanie is
wife god rest her soul
she said you know before he stands like
I want to quit I want to do this anymore
he wants to write the Great American
Novel
and she's like before you do that why
don't you just write something that you
want to write write anything you want
write your thing write what you would
write if you were in charge and that was
fantastic for number one so without it
you don't get the Marvel Universe you
know it doesn't bring him to Jack Kirby
the rest of the history doesn't happen
Steve Ditko doesn't get involved and so
forth and so on so I have nothing but
respect for them i this is of course
sacré sacrilege to admit but my
Fantastic Four was Reed Richards Sue
Storm Ben Grimm and Herbie the robots
because on TV they didn't want to show
the Human Torch
in case kids were like now you be the
torch and they lie to each other about
fire so there was a season where they
did the Fantastic Four and Herbie the
robot was the [ __ ] fourth and he was
cracking wise and [ __ ] like that so that
was my introduction to the FF and stuff
and then when they were like there's a
guy who in the comics who's always on
[ __ ] fire I was like that's so metal
but uh that smart-aleck II robot yeah he
was the original member of the Fantastic
Four for me somebody should make like
the serendipity slash sliding doors
movie of Joni and Stan meeting for the
first time oh yeah like the sort of
romance that if it doesn't go together
you know somebody's got the [ __ ]
Superman cape or the the picture
everything goes you're absolutely right
if they don't meet she never says you
should write what you want he don't
write the Fantastic Four we're not
sitting here waiting fern and Avengers
in a couple of weeks he's just as sad
not at all rich dude in New York just
doing shitty comics that he hates and
Joanie's living our life and we are the
worst for it he tells the story I we met
her it was a he went to this party in
New York and he knocked on the door and
she answered and he said something
really lovely to her I can't remember
what he said and stuff but he said
something that of like at first I even
hear it because I'm like you didn't talk
about your dick it's very sweet yeah I
was like [ __ ] that's monkey but it's
very very sweet meet-cute story but my
god you're right if they don't meet that
moment don't happen
or better yet you have the actual Marvel
heroes crossover from a fictional
dimension into our dimension to make
sure that they meet otherwise that
dimension doesn't exist and they don't
sorry that is Avengers 4 right oh my god
on your face 5 mr. [ __ ] oh all right
Vanessa for have not been published as a
monthly comic by Marvel you know quite a
while yes if I remember correctly they
stopped about three years ago and a lot
of people speculated they never came out
and said why they're like oh yeah we're
just we're just we hate Fox no that was
kind of they didn't wanna they were like
why are we doing Fox's work forums
they've got fantastic four we've got the
comics just like x-men they stopped in
an x-men for a minute is why cuz I used
to have 48 x-men comics a month right it
was like Wolverine has one and maybe
there's a main line next title and
that's it and maybe now that Fox and
Disney have made some sort of peace well
yeah if they were trying to starve him
out it didn't work they were just fine
instead but yes the Fantastic Four
coming back to Marvel Comics written by
Dan Slott art by Sarah Pacelli
I believe she's the first female artist
on the Fantastic Four regular run if i
if the internet is to be trusted but the
internet told me that I was worth 30
million dollars and I know that's not
[ __ ] true so I don't know but yeah I
think is she may be the first female
artist yeah well that's good that's a
good sign that means they're coming if
it's gonna happen in the books that
means they'll be coming theatrically
sooner than we realize it a lot of
speculation about what's gonna go on in
Avengers 4 because by the time that's
all wrapped up all those Fox x-men
characters and in Fantastic Four
characters including the lactis come
over but I would imagine like maybe you
save your Galactus for the next [ __ ]
phase like the way they built up to a
Thanos now they could build up to a
Galactus right especially because
Avengers 4 is mostly done yeah they shot
at the same time they shot Avengers 3
yeah no movie has ever gone back for
reshoots Deadpool just literally [ __ ]
said that they went back to add
something in I know I know but like that
that kind of massive structural
engineering of oh [ __ ] now we have all
of these amazing characters to make part
of it I don't know they would have to
know far earlier than we did
which they probably did I was gonna say
that feels like that deal was in the
often for a long [ __ ] time maybe the
urgency had something to do with like
re-up [ __ ] coming up all right
that's good to know what else we good
did you ever read the Tommyknockers
Stephen King book I did not I love that
title it's always this little something
so satisfying never opened up the book
god damn it he gave it to me right there
on the cover there but yes Warner
Brothers I think it might be taking a
run at the time what is it about it is
about hold on I have a synopsis right
here I'll [ __ ] out it's coming
through now Connor this story focuses on
a touch should I do it in my newsreader
voice please do okay sorry focus is not
a town in Maine that falls under the
influence of a dangerous gas from
another spacecraft the gas begins to
transform the people give me them
enhanced abilities but also making them
violent and subject to an alien hive
mentality one man thanks to a steel
plate in his head is immune to the
effects and tries to stop the town
people news 11
I can't tell your performance took me
out of the piece I'm sorry no I was just
listening to you go wow he's got a
character and I forgot about so they're
aliens Duke has a metal plate in his
head is penny wise in it
no it's doomed she's a TV show or movie
it will be a movie James Wan he of the
Aquaman Fame wow it's good all the
inside word is that it's really good
yeah and Roy Lee who produced it yeah
bring us the [ __ ] Stephen King back to
the cinema yeah he's having a moment
yeah so Roseanne did you uh she's having
a lot of them did you watch it I did not
watch it did you watch I did how do you
feel about honestly as a [ __ ] long I
loved the original run of the show even
season nine has merit moments moments of
merit even
went way off the rails but the two
episodes I watched last week and then
there's one I guess that's on tonight so
I'll be able to watch it tomorrow like
the second episode stand shoulder to
shoulder with the best episodes of the
run of the show really the opening
episode was the one that was most
political but it wasn't even political
it wasn't like she was you know [ __ ]
oh my god the president rules like she
voted for him Jackie didn't to create
some [ __ ] tension and fodder in the
show but insanely well done first off
and foremost funny made me laugh out
loud in a couple places yes some of them
of course we're like nostalgic laughs of
like I love this family but there's some
like legit [ __ ] great jokes on number
two like totally works as a reboot you
it's like oh my god they haven't missed
a beat almost like they've been doing
the show since they did its but it's a
stronger stuff so far than the previous
last season was so I'd liked it a lot I
look forward to watching it tonight I
thought they did a great [ __ ] job and
I you know a lot of people like I'm
gonna watch it she likes [ __ ] Trump
and [ __ ] I mean it's not like my wife is
no fan of the President and she was a
huge fan of Roseanne and then she was on
the fence about watching it because
Roseanne is pretty you know pro Trump
and stuff I told her I was like honestly
like works like the show is really good
she watched it and she fell in love with
it too
so if she can like get over it I think
anybody that's got an issue with
Roseanne's politics might be able to get
over it's well made hysterical [ __ ]
television and it's very subversive you
up front the talent you all you're
hearing about is how much you know she
loves Trump but underneath they're
making a [ __ ] show that kind of
stands for everything that organization
whether the administration seems to
stand against man so it's worth keeping
on it's definitely worth watching
I enjoyed it does it function the same
way that say all in the family did its
that's kind of what it feels like now
the first run of the show they weren't
that show where they were definitely
like blue collar middle America but this
incarnation the show definitely feels
like it's got a nice sue song of all
family kind of poured on top of it and
on the family also people like Archie
Bunker wasn't off-putting America
[ __ ] loved Archie Bunker he said
off-putting things but like we this
country's cheered a conservative on
before it's not like a huge [ __ ]
stretch particularly cuz the two
episodes I watched she's not out there
[ __ ] waving a flag or anything she's
making jokes and so far two jokes been
good and that's what you want out of a
sitcom
I got no skin in the game I put up a
tweet about it somebody was like you're
sucking Roseanne's dick I was like she's
got one I got no skin in the game I just
like good [ __ ] TV and I was so
relieved and happy that that show was
what it turned out to be I hope it stays
stays the course John Goodman I [ __ ]
love him and [ __ ] like that it's nice
seeing him talking back out there Loren
Metcalfe's wonderful you know [ __ ] was
fantastic was what yeah he was in red
state was Sara Gilbert really sad a
chick from the view those are the top
one of those something's she was she
played Darlene and then after that
didn't really do a [ __ ] ton of acting
she was in a couple movies and then
she's been doing this TV show for years
but she has like she owns the third act
of the first episode she has an
emotional breakdown which is like legit
good acting like he could totally get
Emmy nominated for it and they seem to
be using her character more than
anything else to con tell story she is
like young Roseanne Sun degree she's the
kid of the three that's most like her
mom so but man like who knew she can act
like as well as she can she was always
great on the show but like she came back
with serious [ __ ] chops I would not
be shocked if she got an Emmy not this
season it's even though it's only what
ten episodes I don't know how many
they're doing I mean it's already been
greenlit for season two yeah how could
they not the ratings like it opened like
they said eighteen and then final number
is 25 million people yeah watching a TV
program which is like those we haven't
heard those numbers in [ __ ] years man
unless it's a sporting event or
something like that so that's kind of
huge man it's kind of huge alright where
to next last bit of news okay tomorrow
will mark the 50th anniversary of the
of 2001 a Space Odyssey 56 really yes
Wow with that the first one of the first
to use miniatures and [ __ ] like that
you were Star Wars even yeah like lots
of that sort of like not quite this in
computer control that ILM had patented
but a lot of the early blue screen a lot
of the early miniatures a lot of the
early like rear projection II stuff
right and just the exact in nature of
Kubrick's direction like even the
[ __ ] Forrest perspective and then
down the barrel perspective and that the
we're mounting a camera and treating
this as of at zero-g like just all of
those inventions that we take for
granted so often today in cinema started
with that movie where do you stand on
that movie I don't love that movie
it's insanely well-made but let's get
high i watch 2001 yeah or if you don't
get high let's watch 2001 it's a really
good time it's totally it's set but it's
insanely [ __ ] well-made yeah but in
terms of the Kubrick library you know I
have nothing but respect for it but like
it's no shining The Shining I could
watch couple nights back-to-back in a
row it was just insanely well made and
more I guess at my alley yeah there's
something there's something very
antiseptic about Stanley Kubrick for me
like there's never a ton of emotion
coming through I mean The Shining has
very specific you know ways that that
kind of argues that point right but
first so much of his work it feels very
hermetically sealed like there's no air
in the room when he directs that gets
very because he's doing 98 takes of
everything there's no spontaneity
there's not a lot of life going on on
the on the stage but it's so [ __ ]
beautiful to look at it so it's oh it's
a work of perfection not a work of
inspiration for me interesting he is
there's a shirt I watched once online
that lined up all these symmetrical
shots that he's put in movies and it's
visually dazzling like the dude painted
but you're right as stuff it's not like
whenever I want to feel good and [ __ ] i
watch your eyes watch because that's
what marriage is man when you spent all
your time obsessing over some sale or
your wife might have [ __ ] that's all
the news we why'd you bring it up just
gives us 50 years old is 50 years old
tomorrow and that's [ __ ] huge man
happy birthday mm yeah I saw a movie
this week I forgot to mention it was
based on a comic book
I killed Giants how was that I'm really
curious about I enjoyed it I thought it
was very watchable and I liked it it had
a you know [ __ ] imagination - it's
based on the comic book that Joe Casey I
think it was your belly Joe Kelly it's
one of the Joe's yeah I want to say it's
Casey but I'm gonna fight you on it's
one of the they're both a man of action
man of action yeah and also two huge
names from like 90's comics legendary
names but it was well done man it was on
iTunes and I was clicking through Isaac
this looks [ __ ] dope and now the
monster calls no I saw most of those I
haven't see it kill Giants but I
understand that there are some
similarities between the two really in
that genre about girls and monsters it's
more about children and imaginary
creatures sort of being brought to life
and the subjective reality of people
around them who do or do not believe in
the reality of the monsters that that
better summoned and those Massa is sure
that describes the movie I watched and
those monsters are a stand-in for some
other serious life event that is sort of
encroaching in in monster calls it was
the main characters mother was dying and
so he wanted this monster to help him
deal with all the [ __ ] that he couldn't
deal with it his mother used to help him
with spoilers spoilers then spoilers for
the other movie michiel giant same thing
coming really yeah apparently this is a
new genre but it was totally watchable I
watched it like I couldn't sleep one
night and so about 2:30 in the morning I
was like maybe I'll watch this got
blazed and watched a movie about [ __ ]
preteen girls felt real weird
but it was pretty good pretty good I was
watching it no you never see a movie
with like you know young girls is the
lead or something like that but the
effects were cool as well now like this
it was worth a spin I I finally finished
Jessica Jones oh [ __ ] how'd that go
was it a pleasure or a family visit it
was a bit it was a sip it took me longer
to get through season 2 by far than it
sent me to get through season 1 but I
loved season 1 it is still for me the
best of them all those shows really yeah
better than daredevil ujj I know ok
better than Luke Cage I think that I
think that what Jessica Jones season 1
has to say is more interesting than
those movies I'll never forget the only
Marvel anything I've ever seen Marvel
film the entertainment of any kind where
they not only say the word abortion but
it's a [ __ ] plot point of the fetus
that got aboard a man or the like hey
man the abortion like alright I guess
it's modern world we could all deal with
that [ __ ] and then all of a sudden
they're like I pulled this from the lab
it's a dead baby I was like this [ __ ]
is a Marvel show I don't think the
Falcons gonna be showing up here anytime
Grant man but yeah I mean the first
season is very much about PTSD is very
much about survivor's guilt yeah much
about endurance about not not succumbing
to the past even when the past is may
present the second season is it it
harmonizes with that a little bit it's
very much about Jessica's past but a
part of her past that I wasn't that
curious about you know who's her mother
where'd she come from how did she get
made odd those are not she get made how
did she get that whole episode with her
like her parents [ __ ]
yeah we did made like her power yeah
like where did she's not she's not born
with it she's not born this way she was
she was built in wow spoilers built in a
laugh and so it's it's very much about
like filling in the blanks that I didn't
need filled in for this character and
and sort of introducing us to her mother
and what that relationship was like you
know it's Patsy Trish Walker kind of
going down this deep spiral of addiction
that she had been clean for a while and
watching characters continue to do
things that you know they shouldn't do
and there's any number of ways okay
they could be that dude loves it when
characters make terrible decisions
downward spiral yo it's true actually to
be fair it's like without characters
making bad decisions we don't have
anything to watch that should they make
good decisions like and the show's over
right but it becomes like is every
decision she's gonna make a bad one yeah
for like 13 episodes every call she
makes is the wrong call and after a
while you just begin to hate a character
who keeps doing dumb [ __ ] over and over
again and there's like just once just
[ __ ] do the right thing no all right
I guess not I liked it I didn't love it
it was it was it was harder to watch
than I thought it would be even though
there was a pretty great moment some
really good character turns and I feel
like season 3 would be stronger than
season 2 from where they left and how
they set it up is it standalone from the
rest of the Marvel Universe do they
bring in anybody or reference the
defenders adventure at all
they they they reference a little bit
here and there but like you never see
Luke Cage you never see any of the other
defenders really right what they
reference Captain America's a doll yeah
and who foggy Nelson shows up for like a
heartbeat in the Jessica show yeah so if
you're a completist yes you should
totally watch it if you're just like hey
what should i watch this week because i
woman to mood for something good i don't
know man
it's Marvel so at any point it was
Jessica Jones like Thanos is coming
they're all gonna [ __ ] go down this
all doesn't mean a Philippine yeah not
so much
alright that's so that's definitely I'm
like to watch list I'll get to that
what's the next one the next Marvel
series uh Luke Cage in June Luke Cage
season 2 is June I know that they've
they're shooting Punisher season 2 now
punishes happening again daredevil ones
I don't know what is it
we're getting rioters oh we're all gonna
get iron-fisted one more time but they
have not announced daredevil season 3
yet I don't think so I want to see
that's what I'm most interested cloak
and dagger well I'm gonna freeform that
yes it's on freeform right have they
piloted yet the trailer I thought look
yeah I think it premieres in the next
month or so I made so the the even the
off like grants not off brand but the
like off [ __ ] Marvel Studios Marvel
shows I like The Runaways that was solid
I have to catch up on Legion before I
[ __ ] watch the season premiere cuz I
that came back as well
it comes back tonight how many episodes
was season one eight yeah I'm shown my
ignorant I still haven't watched it and
I really should do you think it's you
haven't watched it either
it made me feel stupid every episode
well I'm just like I don't know what's
happening here and I've been paying
attention so you want to be grudging I'm
like I'm halfway good at watching [ __ ]
and I can't figure how what's going on
here did it ever come together again
I've been told it comes together on
episode 6 of 8 when did you jump ship
I jumped you before because I'm like
[ __ ] you if I have to wait 6 episodes
for it to get good I have a life to [ __ ]
to do
fair enough that is that is 970 minutes
that I got to give something before he
gets good yeah [ __ ] that I've jumped out
of relationships before then
now listen this isn't in like six weeks
in and it's not good yet so will you go
back and finish before you watch the new
if you want Willie well that's the thing
like when I can summon the intentional
fortitude to dive back into Legion
season one is when I will kick back into
season two I don't know dude you got
through iron fist
I did I did well that was that was more
like a hate watch that like propels you
through with the venom and bile and all
of those good feelings that just beat
you up from the dead dragon eats his
[ __ ] ass where's your interest now
Game of Thrones got live dragons you
[ __ ] cheap [ __ ] all right mans edit
that one over the news folks put your
heads together
[Applause]
all right now lookie lookie here man we
come to the part of the show where you
guys get to play along you don't get to
sit here and watch this [ __ ] ramble
at each other you get to ramble at us
and we will ramble back at you we're
gonna be doing the QA part of the show
ladies gentlemen begins right now JC bar
proprietor the [ __ ] Bea Arthur of
this Cantina bar we'll pick some people
and you'll stand over here where we have
a camera pointed at you and stuff and
we'll have a conversation five people
get to ask questions ladies and
gentlemen hopefully five if we go more
it's because one of the questions was
strong enough the only rule that we have
is the question has to apply to both me
and mark and stuff and if you do that
correctly you will win not only a pair
of 4dx tickets if you have not seen a
movie in 40x
save these tickets and go see the
[ __ ] Avengers movie in 40x
change your life oh my god it's and you
know if some people like I couldn't pay
for those kind of that's too much pay
for a movie here's your chance to
[ __ ] see that [ __ ] for free man and
I've seen a movie it's fantastic
attached to that we also have folks
giving out free tickets to a show
they're doing called solo must die
it's a han solo comedy show and it's
taken place at the Hudson backstage
theater which is over on Santa Monica
Boulevard man so you get some 40 X
tickets and I feel like I want to spend
some [ __ ] tickets but I can't go to
40 X until April 27 then you could go
see solo which you can't go until May
4th so I was wrong about that as well
May 4th to the 27th man solo must die
dot-com for those who are 9 original
songs it's not parody musical tube used
May 4th at the Hudson backstage so if
you're a geek you might [ __ ] love
this man just before the release of the
highly anticipated solo a Star Wars
story fans will have an opportunity to
revisit their favorite space smuggler as
he sings and dances his troubles away in
this new musical comedy if you ever
wanted to [ __ ] shoot on first here's
your chance man solo the musical so
we're giving away tickets everybody who
asks a question that passes muster gets
240 X tickets and two tickets to go
there is not a song that's called I know
in that [ __ ] this musical that's right
there needs to be but if you don't do
the big romance ballad where he sings I
know when and the chorus is just I love
you I know way to [ __ ] on their musical
man I'm just saying you still have like
a month and a half to get the I know
song in there that's true he's got a
good point like might want to take it to
Boston all right here we go JC did you
pick somebody and then the questions
begin in earnest ladies and gentlemen
what's your name man
what is Shannon joy everyone give it up
for Shannon
[Music]
tears were she's in Washington oh she's
always more important I know right
okay you guys remember a while back when
there was this picture of Obama and he's
shooting skeet shooting
and so he's it's him skeet shooting this
gun and the internet went crazy way that
they made they photoshopped it and all
these things were my favorite one was
when he was in the Dukes of Hazzard car
he's like shooting it possibly right
exactly and I looked at that and I
thought that'd be fun if it was in a
video game so I looked around and nobody
made a video game out of that and so I
made one where he's shooting these
disposable enemies you know just wave
after wave of them and it's called Obama
vs. the devil chickens any way you look
at ups Obama vs. deviltry but then later
that Obama versus Obama the devil
chickens
it's an uber droid Gamescom but if you
just look up either one of those you'll
find it okay but I like how you help
people plug things you're like a really
good way I'm a pro yes but anyway I
looked at that before it I thought I
thought somebody must have already done
that somebody must have made a game out
of that nobody did you know there was a
I looked and looked so I made one but
then I later on I saw this movie where
these two really iconic characters punch
and kick wave after wave of these
disposable enemies called broad seas and
I looked and looked at nobody made a
video game out of that look like is
screaming to be a video game you know
monster somebody to make a video game of
it people would have had to seen it
first and that was our big problem well
let me tell you I I made that way after
that picture was relevant so you know
nobody's ever played it this is probably
the most attention it's ever gonna get
what is it what did you do did you so
you think it should be a game oh it's
got a boss monster at the end it's got
they pick up weapons there's like mid
bosses that are the warehouse satanic
people that you know they think they can
pick up a knife they can get both they
can raise levels there's it's it's meant
it's like it's got a boss monster at the
I come on
yes it's custom designed the enemies do
sample your boner but I mean that's
perfect
it's a perfect video game thing it's
screaming you reminded me of all the
dreams I had for this movie before you
know it came out if nobody made a video
game out of it yet I don't know why and
I want to make that game how can I make
what do I have to do to make me a yoga
okay - yeah I won't sue you to worry
about if I was you know and I even
thought about like genius that would be
like - that'd be too much for me to buy
that would be like a tactical war
simulation and you gotta place your
snipers here and there and you gotta
four marks comma go these units to place
but if anyone did do that I would think
her dialogue to the enemy is a weapon
because she's always manipulating them
and I don't know how how intentional
that is and how much but I'm you know
it's everything she says he's like
warfare based on deception she's like
she's manipulating them but she's also
she's telling like the truth but just
what they need to hear to do what to get
them to do what she wants you know so
it's very I would I would use her
dialogue as a weapon along with the
weapons you know yeah but that's more
that's that would be you would have to
have like people would have to like work
a year on that to do it
any kind of justice at all you know I
can make punching and kicking brought
cease though you know like parks that
will take quality your [ __ ] I can get
done on a weekend that's a kind of a
question both of you has anybody talked
to you about that like nobody has talked
to me about doing a yoga hosers a game I
saw somebody online I did a picture of
what an 8-bit version of yogurt look
like which I thought was adorable but no
nobody is ever well I mean but not about
yoga's Trevor Furman who was in clerks -
he plays Elias the character of allies
him and his buddy
wanted to make a Jay and Silent Bob
video game and they've been doing it
they did a not a Kickstarter but a fig
is the video game version of Kickstarter
so they raised a bunch of loot and
they've been building that for like the
last year so
I think it's called Jane Samba blunt
chronic punch but it'll be like a little
while before it's done but nobody's ever
asked me about doing a video game
I always [ __ ] wish they would I've
read Sega was talking to Universal about
doing a Mallrats game before Mallrats
came out then it came out in the life
we're good no what about you sir nobody
has ever come to me looking to acquire a
piece of IP for a specific purposes of
making a game I would say yes if they
did but nobody has today we it would be
a lot of work and the same I would want
the same artists and all of that I would
be happy to let somebody do a lot of
work yeah every game we got an idea for
a game in the game is a boy and his mom
rolling around Los Angeles going the
tourists are man you wouldn't dig his
bag dick give it up for him ladies and
gentlemen nobody ever has that before
all right JC bring us their excellent
shirt yes way to go
thank you very much your name my name is
Robert give it up for Robert lazy keV
thank you for signing Muertos blu-ray I
wrote on the tusks [ __ ] yeah yeah thank
you very much he gave me a red pen to
write on a red cover that was [ __ ] up
right now bro you the speaker of truth
for that corner over there right yeah
that's my little brother
it's his 27th birthday
named Jonathan what is the Honest John
Jonathan Jonathan it's an oldie but a
goodie here we go three one two three
happy birthday
once let's do a pass man here now you're
gonna get blown tonight as well
this is Batman I'm Batman and this is
our this is the started with our Lord
and Savior Batman and throughout the
years
Batman has lost his way you know
Marvel has been taking over and DC has
been been taken to the side a bit my
question to you is with Matt Reeves
writing the Batman and directing the
Batman and your old friend Affleck today
playing the best yeah
today he opted out of Dallas where he
opted out of Dallas well she was going
to do a Q&A at Dallas Comic Con or
Dallas I saw two two yesterday there was
an ad for Affleck was going to the comic
balance which was [ __ ] huge he'd
never gone anywhere near that world
other than like San Diego to stand on
the stage and promote so he was gonna go
do Q&A and pictures and but now he's
only going to do a signing he's not
gonna do the Q&A which raises the
question you know he probably doesn't
want to hear the are you gonna be in the
Batman are you gonna do this or giving
you that
yeah I'd imagine that'd be a nightmare q
a night for that guy
right so ask to our Lord and Savior
Batman what do you what would you do
with the Batman how do you get the
Batman to the top where you should be I
think they're characters so ubiquitous
he's never leaving like he'll always be
at the top of something the the movies
lately you know haven't kind of that he
certainly looks like [ __ ] Batman but
they haven't really moved people like
the Nolan's stuff did you know I
this character is now cycling into the
hands of somebody else as you mentioned
Matt Reeves and stuff so there's another
chance that you fall
love the character when it's in the
hands of somebody else III fine
Snyder's version like fascinating what
kind of flawed he's he's a Batman but
he's not my Batman but I can't like I'm
not like he never should have done it I
liked it for what it is and stuff but I
do look forward to like if you listen to
me on like the episode of fat man I'm
Batman where I'm reviewer might have
been smart guess where I'm reviewing
like The Dark Knight Rises - Scott
Mosier Scott's like I'm never gonna see
this movie so I was like I will tell you
everything and it's about a two-hour
retelling of the [ __ ] movie during
which I'm crying and Scott is like I
can't believe can't believe this is
happening it's totally so I I look
forward to feeling that way about the
character again in the cinematic world
I've cried at current Batman movies but
for a different reason all together and
still so are you know I'm glad he's
still around I don't think he's going
anywhere I don't have any fixes so to
speak I'm not like you know what they're
[ __ ] doing wrong I believe me I got
no cure for this I'm a fan I just I I
appreciate any version I get some I love
more than others and stuff but I think
your own always ever just one cool
[ __ ] flick away from that character
going right back to the top of the box
office we hope now like you know Batman
as characters always captured
imaginations is always done well
cinematically even these current
incarnations have it's not like they
haven't made money eight hundred million
bucks is nothing to [ __ ] sneeze that
which is what Batman V Superman did but
we do now live in a world where it's
just like here's black panther and
here's like whoever's coming out of
Avengers and here the next new heroes
here ant-man ant-man puts up a
devastating [ __ ] trailer for their
second film and you're like holy [ __ ]
like I can't believe I look this forward
to this [ __ ] movie and stuff and it's
not a Batman movie so as much as Batman
has kind of you know defined the
cinematic superhero for a long long
[ __ ] time it it might it's gonna take
something really [ __ ] special to make
people go like oh yeah a Batman
so what would you do what would I do
personally honestly like this is gonna
be it sounds stupid but I would do what
Warner Brothers seems to be doing right
now which is like we're not gonna try to
make a universe anymore we're just gonna
do what we've always done and give
certain movies to certain people and let
them go off and do their version of the
character so the notion of like the Todd
Phillips Joker movie is kind of
interesting to me Matt Reeves solo
Batman movies interesting to me I don't
think they should you just be making
[ __ ] like 200 million dollar [ __ ]
Batman movies they don't need to you
could do a [ __ ] 50 million dollar
cool horror version of that moose yet
for even less Arkham Asylum if they are
gonna do Grant Morrison's Arkham Asylum
takes place in one [ __ ] location man
bunch of spooky rooms with the rogues
gallery
everybody's [ __ ] in it so unless you
don't like go like let's overpay for
talent which you really don't [ __ ]
need to because a lot of people aren't
makeup and [ __ ] like that you can cast
that movie pretty simply and shoot that
movie for like 50 million bucks if a
Batman movie can make eight hundred to a
billion and it does it on a two hundred
million dollar budget it's just more
profit in a 50 million dollar film and
something to talk about because it
sounds like it could be an interesting
project as well in smaller hands with a
tighter vision or something like that
different than like let's just make it
big and over-the-top I think they need
to pirouette man they need to [ __ ]
pivot like and do something different
I hope Matt Reeves is to live the rumors
are like he's doing the Dark Knight
Detective kind of you know old version
of Batman that might be interesting and
you know as opposed to the same [ __ ]
thing that we've seen over and over
again so games on their stick but that
character in the right hands has always
controlled the tension
problem is that character had the
spotlight to itself for a long long long
[ __ ] time and now we live in a world
where like Ironman is as cool and
well-known as a Batman character so what
would I do
I honestly I would do what they're doing
right now which is like let's just start
making movies that aren't connected
don't worry about that universe don't
worry about tying things together we
they were masters at this [ __ ] they
mastered the comic book movie in the 70s
of Superman in the late 80s early 90s
with Batman they have the [ __ ] Dark
Knight trilogy like
they should be able to do this in their
[ __ ] sleep so I think you know
they'll they'll reboot Batman again has
that many [ __ ] times and this
incarnation might capture people's
imagination a little more than the
current one it's kind of heartbreaking
man that Justice League like is
considered unsuccessful like you know
that's that's weird
like it's yeah and I mean it's not as
sad it's like you know there are [ __ ]
people dying in countries and [ __ ] like
that it's sad in a first world away
where we got no real skin in the game
other than the fact that we've loved
these characters and Marvel fans a
Marvel fan it was I was happy when
[ __ ] Avengers did what when it did
like a billion dollars and you were like
see this legitimizes [ __ ] that I always
[ __ ] liked I knew I wasn't stupid
but then Justice League comes out people
like you were saying you know so so you
know there's a bit of disappointment
just because you love those characters
and you love to see it Justice League
movie and we finally got one and you're
like yeah it was [ __ ] totally
watchable and stuff but there'll be
another one out there one day that's
gonna feel more like the way I felt when
I would read Grant Morrison's line of
Justice League comes when he did JLA for
a while or or I'll even take
Superfriends at this point man where
they'll [ __ ] like each other you know
[ __ ] but since your podcast is Batman
I'm Batman
how would you bring Batman back to the
top yeah mark ao6 Warner Brothers would
you two things time and anticipation I
think you need to give Batman a little
bit of time to rest fallow I just want
people in the world to hear the coast of
fat man on Batman be like I think we've
seen enough Batman for a while let's
give it a rest but no I think that that
the thing that benefited Batman Begins
was a space between Batman and Robin and
Batman Begins like time for us to forget
what had come before and I think that
like no matter what you think of Justice
League or Batman V Superman the idea of
if you loved it
you want it to fade from your memory a
little bit so you can open yourself up
to something new if you hated it
you need the pain of that memory to be
able to fade into the distance of it
either way time only helps and I think
you need to - as much as I agree with
Kevin that making everything
interconnected does not seem to be DC's
move find a way to build story
anticipation for Batman to return to the
stage make your Batgirl movie make your
Nightwing movie make your Joker movie if
you want to not that I think you need to
tell that ordinance story but whatever
the [ __ ] make it so that you are setting
the stage for this character to return
in a big bad way make it so that the
characters in these movies are waiting
for him to return make it so that he is
not just answering our prayers of a
great Batman but character prayer so the
[ __ ] Batman to come in and save
Gotham City I think if you can press
down on both meta and legit narrative
pressure of making us want him back so
badly that way it began it becomes
something Universal in a way that it's
currently not you know I mean I think
Kevin is right that the world in which
we don't see another Batman movie is not
this world no but you're absolutely
right they should put him away for a
little bit they make a few Wonder Woman
movies and yes doubling that and then
come back to him but he's been their
cash cow for so long and it seems like
they're as baffled as anybody I like
what do we do in a world where a Batman
movie doesn't [ __ ] make all the money
and still concentrate on what you got
working and Wonder Woman seems to be
working great and so yeah you're right
let's put them away for a little bit
they're gonna make another one of a
movie they're shooting Shazam right now
Alka menace in the can and then they are
kind of tabula rasa like they don't have
any commitments to do anything no they
may never make that cyborg movie they
may never make flashpoint who knows like
people say they want to but who knows
maybe they shouldn't maybe it should
just be hard reset let's just sit down
collect her breath a little bit and I
figure out the best way to again bring
this giant [ __ ] icon of popular
culture back to the screen in a real way
yeah to what degree I yeah well you know
I it's funny I think about it a lot cuz
like we get I get dinged on Twitter all
the time about people being like it's
called fat man that me I'm really [ __ ]
talk about Batman I'm like well give me
something to talk about
like cinematically you know it's it's it
looked like it was gonna be a [ __ ]
like really verdant time with like oh
[ __ ] here come a whole new series of
movies and Batman's made Superman and
stuff and you know it just got tougher
and tougher to talk about you know a
Batman I'm on a show called fat man I'm
Batman when you're like I don't really
like the you know what's happening as
much with Batman but boy those Marvel
movies are great you know so that's why
the show kind of expanded more to just
embrace pop culture in general but I you
know look Batman is my first hero and
yes he'll never be bad it's it's he'll
be back and stuff but but marks got a
point maybe they should put him on a
shelf for a little bit let him mourn his
parents for a year or two if I remember
correctly the [ __ ] one time he quit
for eight [ __ ] years for no good
reason so clearly he could take a few
years off that was a great question take
your tickets man give it up firmly
[Applause]
guys yours Oh your oh thank you
hi what's your name Laurie ever give it
up a Laurie man okay everyone give it up
for Doris Doris Doris that's bad I can't
ever hear people from over there it
always comes up bra but now it's Dori
did I just make that like 800th finding
dory Joe okay and your writers mind oh
[ __ ] you wrote a question yeah I'm
prepared Dory did not suck him play so
did the word couldn't remember [ __ ] she
should have written jiff Kevin good
point
it's very on-brand Doria had that
problem with her phone underwater as
well some might be hard with fins
it's a droid and your writers mind do
you see God as a woman in dogma as in
dogma or is a God image in your mind the
bearded individual that looks like Bryan
Johnson
haha oh my god is that why I like Bryan
Johnson so much like Hello Lord
let's see man I guess because I was
raised this way because there were
really no pictures of God other than
like Jesus which if you're Catholic you
believe in the Blessed Trinity is three
persons in one God the Father the Son
and the bird so
so there was never really any like
depictions of God even in church other
than the Vatican with God creating Adam
and stuff that's the only image they
ever gave you of God and so I had that I
went to eight years of Catholic school
like that's the looming image of the
Lord's me that's why when I did dogmas
like I'm gonna try to scrub this from my
brain and make it a woman and so making
it Ilana certainly helped me forget
about the Vatican but I don't think I
think of God as gender at all just like
like it's kind of like sounds like a
cheap get a cheap cop-out but I did make
cop out but I was raised Catholic and I
you know it's like I certainly don't
have the faith that I used to as a kid
but hold on a little just in case you
know in case I die and they're like you
were wrong [ __ ] I was like I
still got some faith left but that being
said I feel like like you know remember
when they did Galactus in the Fantastic
Four movie that's God like just just a
big old purple cloud that [ __ ] says
[ __ ] and whatnot
yeah that's I'm not creative enough I me
not the other than the one [ __ ] shot
at Dogma which to be fair Atlantis
brought like all the cute aspects of
that character like I had her being
quiet she and she was only quiet because
it was meant to be played by Holly
Hunter who and the piano had played a
mute so and then Holly Hunter was like
I'm not doing this movie and so we had
to find another God we were godless and
then we found Emma Thompson at first
Alan Rickman brought her on but then she
didn't stay because she was gonna go try
to go have a baby I think so then we
were wide open again and then it wound
up being Alanis who had asked her to be
in the lead playing Bethany at one point
but she was like that's too big a role I
couldn't like act that much I haven't
acted since Nickelodeon so she went away
to India came back just as we were about
to start shooting and she's like you
know I I want to reconsider like I know
you probably I went to India I feel
great I feel like rested and centered
and I
you offered me a role in the flag and I
know it's probably you know you've cast
that part but if there's any roles left
like I would love to come and play and I
was like there is one small but crucial
role left to play in the movie so I well
I'll always have that image of God in my
head is has Atlantis especially because
like she was the one that was like I
want to do a headstand and I was like oh
my god [ __ ] do it and the first time
she did it we all forgot she was wearing
a dress for like oh my god put on boxers
and and I was like you ought to know and
and so but she brought the kind of
playfulness to it and stuff oh that's my
favorite version of God but you know I'm
probably way off on that one but that's
the most imaginative I could get with
the character I always like people that
are like you're [ __ ] wrong Cthulhu is
God I'm like he's insanely well drawn so
yeah about you I I'm like you was not
raised in a religious house are you
serious yes you didn't have any [ __ ]
faith shoved down your throat no there
it was like vaguely judeo-christian and
then like we have to go to a funeral
I guess that's at a church let's go to a
church or a wedding but it was never we
never went every Sunday I never what was
gonna happen to people after they died
in your world it was in my current world
in my childhood my world we're still
headed like you were still others gonna
be heaven there's a hell and because we
have to figure out a way you never
thought who runs these places you like I
don't need the backstory I I have since
developed into a godless heathen since
then since then
it was him Lord it was him I see you as
a giant purple cloud how does this no
spectacles testicles wallet and watch is
that one okay did we kill Andrew you
guys oh all right
so godless heathen maybe but yes I later
in life you know parted ways with what
was tangential faith at best but I was
always taken by there was a negative a
gimmick because it was an artistic
choice but in Prince of Egypt they tell
the Moses story they tell the story of
Exodus right and in that movie you never
see God because of God in that story
he's only his voice burning bush it's a
burning bush and it's the voice of God
and the voice of God in that movie was
Val Kilmer's voice Val Kilmer also
played Moses so the idea that the voice
of God is your voice speaking back to
you the things you need to know the idea
that [ __ ] you've reached somebody over
there hears like then you just change
somebody's life with that [ __ ]
religions have been founded unless
particularly in this town if you go down
the block but the idea that that God can
be the best version of you the idea that
that the message you need to hear is a
message only you can receive from
yourself or version of yourself there's
something kind of powerful in that and
narcissistic in the way that [ __ ]
Humanity is but that that that idea that
the version of the unknown the only
thing you can actually revert back to is
the thing you know and the thing you
know most is yourself and so if the
wisdom of the Ancients if the voice of
God is your voice in your face if I am
making it if I'm making a move if I've
got our portrait god that's how I would
do it or Morgan Freeman yes
that's true he's great representation of
God for us when we were kids it was
George [ __ ] burns but that's a pretty
good upgrade I remember there's this
thing changed my life a few years ago
like you know my wife's into yoga and
[ __ ] like that and there was like some
kind of like yoga Prince got Buddha sit
and then and she got writing on it
and I ever looked at it because I'm like
exercise but a couple years back like he
got moved into a hallway in the house
and who's the hallway we're like I let
the dogs out in the morning and stuff so
I'm waiting for him anyway so I'm always
by this thing and then I started looking
at it and reading it cuz I'm like I
didn't bring my phone I might as well
read this and on it it said something
that like changed my life because I
really started thinking about it I was a
go [ __ ] it said may you realize your
divinity in this lifetime and it just
sounded like at first glance like a yoga
type thing to say like the MA stay but
it's an incredibly powerful sentiment it
means before you leave this world may
you realize like exactly what you just
said like you're God and not like you
are the God who controls everything but
like you are the God of your universe
and you're incredibly powerful may you
realize that divinity in this lifetime
before you get out of it man so I don't
know I'm I'm with you on that and I also
think that when I hear God speaking to
me it is in the voice of val kilmer
[Laughter]
you tell you my women as Doc Holliday in
Tombstone so he's like I'm your
huckleberry that was a great question we
never talk about God give it up for a
lazy job alright JC two more sets of
questions man hey what's your hello my
name is David everyone give it up for
David why do you love right into the
wall so they could see it boom hi I had
to bail on my D&D game tonight to be
here oh my god there's a confession
that's gonna get you laid yeah there's a
party without a cleric who's desperately
in dire straights the the agreement made
with my DM to allow me to take the night
off was he asked me to ask you to if you
played D&D or if you have any thing to
say about role-playing I can happily
talk about it I did not roleplay as a
kid I wasn't wealthy enough we didn't
have that kind of disposable income when
my parents are like dice to imagine
things go outside and pretend and so I
never got to enjoy it I love the
Dungeons & Dragons cartoon when I was a
kid which does you know they only
tangentially bears resemblance to the
[ __ ] game
but but no I knew only two people in the
world who do game to word and ears and
stuff and I was always kind of like a
man would hey explain it Hey but never
took the dive D&D curious my whole life
but never licked a dick so I'm still
what I wish I wish that that I don't
know how you play but we don't play it
that way maybe that's why I've never
played yet there's there's a lot of dice
fondling though which is fine
go Mayer Dungeon Master but I would I
honestly I feel like it miss down on
stuff because it seems to have created a
whole generation of show runners in this
town anybody you talk to the works on TV
shows has some D&D familiarity usually
people with a big job and it makes sense
because it seemed was Malcolm Gladwell
say with 10,000 hours anything gonna
make you a genius or some such [ __ ] when
you're [ __ ] playing D&D man and they
play those games for hours and whatnot
that's just writing that's room writing
and from what I understand people bunch
of people around World War two do this
well if you did this what if you ran
into a [ __ ] troll and [ __ ] like that
how many years you've been doing it
I finally got I I didn't I didn't have
anyone as a kid to play wood to play
with I got into it at age 20 ish yeah
I'm having to make a friend who was like
this I mean and that was 15 years ago
and you're deep in I am playing two
games and running another one oh right
now in in my life yeah it must be
amazing to [ __ ] you you could multitask
like crazy look I got three things going
I got your nipples your bush your ass I
got it all happening at once
with a natural gift yeah very true so
let me ask you this man in the world of
D&D and I'm not just trying to be funny
but I am kind of curious since you can
[ __ ] make [ __ ] up
was there ever people who were like and
then the troll sucks your dick and
you're like stop talking about troll
dick sucking like those people try to
sexualize then the first group I was in
we had a couple guys in the in the party
that every time we got to would they
wanted to [ __ ] somebody visit the didn't
do a party for nothing man
the dam builds his whole story he's like
what about the
so what about the watches they don't
have any dicks right um no but I wish I
had been it's never too late one day I
will get into a DMD game I had Dan
Harmon on an episode of SModcast
recently so maybe I'll if I'm gonna lose
my cherry I might as well do it with his
crew he seemed ginger yeah big time he
was talking about on the podcast big
enthusiast what about you you got any
D&D in you boy do I ever I played when I
was in high school I played for three or
four years I think when you're in a New
York in yeah New York in Baldwin Long
Island I had a friend who was a dungeon
master and he said one three or four of
us through campaigns on a regular
regular basis and and it's it's very
true that lots of TV writers in
Hollywood and wherever else they write
TV have at one point I'm gonna get you
that Janet Jackson microphone man so it
comes right to your mouth I mean I'm
sure other people use it now but first
time I ever saw Janet you're gonna but
yeah the idea of collaborative
storytelling the idea of being in a room
with other people and telling a story
together and you're all responsible for
the choices you're making there's a
person who is decided the parameters of
the particular story you're telling
that's the dungeon master that's the
Dutchman's they don't write the whole
game you can write [ __ ] well there's
another they don't write the whole game
but their jobs are as I remember it to
come up with the basic thrust of what
the story is you're going from here to
there use your quest here's what you're
after here's the town's you could go
through unless you make a dumb [ __ ]
left turn at Albuquerque you know here's
here's the first time I've liked ooh
they've got a Bugs Bunny references
perhaps I've missed oh but here's here's
the the the things you're going to be
encountering along the way and but also
being flexible and open enough to
accommodate players who do dumb [ __ ]
[ __ ] and want to have sex with trees
because the trees say well how do I know
to keep the castle isn't in the [ __ ]
tree but I've got a don't nobody acts it
out right just sitting
tables saying what's going on you can
act it out but mostly it's sing around
of like and then I do this and then I
say this to this person there is someone
who's always like then I [ __ ] the tree
again and they're like we got it Derek
how committed you are to performing it
is a case-by-case it's you know dealer's
choice
yeah some people like like I have played
with people who they brought a foam
sword
you know they and me and I hit the guy
sir
real swords or get the [ __ ] out real
swords or you know like once when we had
Smaug podcasts all years back we played
a game called Crimson mystical mages and
it was based on like what I thought
Dungeons & Dragons was and it was a lot
of like people having to blow other
people to get to the next level it's fun
we recorded one episode live was a good
time but I I don't know we should do
that one we should that be fun you could
take my hand lead me into the the DND
darkness here we go
Sam you know that world it's been a
while but I think I still have got the
tattoo on my inner lip they'll still let
me back it's a great question give it up
for him ladies gentlemen gets to get
well done here we go man the night was
your name Steve seafloor I'll give it up
for Steve Steve you got your own Silent
Bob what's this all about this is like
he's my podcast partner he actually
inspired me man all right what is the
name of the podcast first of all
gorillas playground what is it the
gorillas play gorillas play guerrilla
warfare
beautiful how long you been doing this
podcast slide to your left a little bit
man usual suspects you guys will hear
the walls
poor never you stand in front of me good
hug you Janet Janet Jackson member yes
that's right good pull all right man so
the podcast is called guerilla war
guerrillas playground guerrillas
playground excellent job thank you by
the way I'm glad you're still here me
too
[ __ ] what is your question what do
you guys want to talk about first of all
you're talking about rebooting or
talking about Batman screams of Arkham
would be an amazing title for something
like for an arcing screams of Arkham
absolutely but that's something you want
to take a five-year-old to but if you're
gonna reboot it or what about like Teen
Titans there's like no real overall
villain Jason Todd maybe they've teased
the hell out of them in the during the
DC Universe you think Jason Todd is
gonna be the villain of Teen Titans Red
Hood Tim Drake Jason Todd they don't
like each other
same thing with Dick Grayson Nightwing
like I mean I'm all for it like the old
version of me would have been like
that's a lot of taffy to pull to tell
the backstory but they could tell a
pretty clean backstory just give the
character the name and everybody be like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] I haven't heard
anything about the Titans other than a
friend of mine directed an episode and
she said the script was really great in
the episode turned out great and I heard
somebody had seen the pilot and thought
it was really cool the Robin works like
hell there's an episode called Red Hood
episode 7 is called Red Hood oh [ __ ]
what the the news when does that start
airings anybody know still not up there
they haven't done it yet all right so
what's your question well are you gonna
be doing maybe season four of league of
legends of tomorrow
because of Constantine and that humor
fits your ballpark coming in the no gag
reflex humor is your is your ballpark
very very true and religious humor as
well I I I'm happy to go wherever they
invite me in stuff they invited me into
flash they invited me in the Supergirl
I've made it known that I would direct
an arrow but nothing but crickets from
that side of the street
apparently they're doing just fine
they're like we're on season 14 go [ __ ]
yourself
so but legends I was told like that's
the show for you man cuz it's funny you
could handle that show and I was like I
know cuz I can't handle serious at all
but if they asked me to go over I'm
happy to met the showrunner once when I
did the panel they had their the Paley
Center panel but they had it at the
Oscar place and stuff and he was a
really great [ __ ] guy but if they
call I'll be the harpy and also mark
you're a Black Panther fan I am not much
into the content or the IP of Black
Panther I just saw the movie so that's
the existence of my history but I heard
the rumor is that or it's part of the
stories his sister becomes the Black
Panther is that the rapture he does yeah
becomes the king of the undead or
something like that you know cuz why
wouldn't you but yeah I mean there's the
in the whatever it is 50 year history of
Black Panther almost everything is
[ __ ] happened
sure he gets me black panther he gets
exiled he gets dethroned somebody else
takes the throne he comes back in blue
man a mr. white dude understand there's
a bunch of [ __ ] but yeah I mean there's
they have nothing but a well to draw
from should they go forward and they
will go forward just depends on how many
movies they're gonna do I was thinking
of this when I looked at the Billboard
today because they put up all the New
Avengers billboards and they're doing
like groupings of characters really
beautiful stuff but I was you know in
the one I passed coming up Barham they
had black panther and a koi a we know
shuri's in it we know the big battle
takes place in Wakanda since this is
like you know the end is near and
[ __ ] like people are gonna [ __ ]
die like it's not like they're gonna
destroy well Conda the way like Asgard
doesn't exist anymore like now that they
know there's [ __ ] money in Wakanda
like I would imagine any plans they had
for like you know maybe this is the end
of
this is only the beginning for a couple
McDonald's in we're gonna franchise it
[ __ ] hey man yeah I was thinking like
nothing too bad gonna happen in Wakanda
cuz we're gonna go back again and again
and again because that's its own land
they are they where bugs land is it's
gonna be called Wakanda I'm tough to be
a bug it's gonna be part of the Verdean
mine really we work for Disney we saw
you and Barry saw you and your daughter
and we saw you guys okay so now who do
you guys play is it guest on and the
food I do ride prep in the graveyard so
I work graveyard shift what's what
happened what do you mean graveyard
shift I have to clack well I have to
maintain monorail steam engines I gotta
do like boys clothes fantasmic or will
the color whatever they tell us to do we
have to do it shut up we'll lose our
jobs and unemployment is one of these
dudes has security clearance and one
doesn't that just makes me like the park
more like that's that's a cool human
thing of course sooner or later one of
the animatronics has to burst into
[ __ ] play worst night man so wait do
you work during the day or at night
night at night it's like usually someone
departs clothes
yeah like midnight to 7:00 a.m. is using
my regular hours or in midnight - 11
a.m. - what is it like to be in
Disneyland after dark it is amazingly
awesome because you get I saw like Walt
Disney's private office it's inside one
of the cabooses it's not you can't even
see it but creepy so it's pretty cool
and it's called the Lilly Belle it's
this caboose but you don't see the
hidden compartment and he used to do all
those notes and everything in there and
stuff and you had do they do that every
night is there maintenance yeah every
night every single night interesting do
you do you ever see people try to break
in the
after dark he raises mic there you go
right into the test I start it's called
the Roundhouse where the steam engines
the monorails I'll stand like this I'll
see drones flying over and they're
trying to get and sometimes they get
stuck because they're out of range so
they just wait for him to crash or net
guns shoot their smaller ones down are
you [ __ ] no no I'm playing it's
awesome it's so awesome wait a second
you're allowed to tell us that you can
tell you that they have net guns they
have necks for children
I'm the one that fishes them out I have
to fish them out that's awesome man
that's like yeah we shoot people with
rubber bullets no it's right where the
where like Auto via there's like that
little lake area that's where they're
flying over and they get stuck and they
run out of range and then some of the
fogers like called Jim he's like you're
a clever girl it's it's usually people
who work for the media who try to get
like insider like pictures or the
matterhorn know one of them I forget
which one yeah like I was at the top and
I got a perfect view of inside it's just
a lot of skeleton right now it looks
like it's gonna be cool there's one of
those cranes is actually was piecing in
the Millennium Falcon really but you can
see that dangling no no you can see that
like on the Internet you saw the
cockpits you see the turrets no I just
can't tell you anything else today we're
not allowed to go back there it's like
you can't even go to toontown without
being cleared
really it's insane at night I get around
1:00 a.m. that's when like when security
I actually blocks all of a certain area
and you actually show your badge like
three times check you have like I have
toontown level 10 clearance yeah
put the leg right this way mr. Revit
yeah yeah to take your break you got to
show your badge to go into the break
room right of course it's the same way
go in around 11:00 p.m. but we don't we
don't see them once they go in you don't
see them they never come they don't
build you're in the day no that's not
right because they don't want the noise
and all that [ __ ] it's a it's amazing
when you think about I'm not just
blowing them but take a moment to think
they're building an entire [ __ ] world
at night so as not to disturb the
millions of people that [ __ ] come
through there every day right like [ __ ]
that's that's gonna mean while like I'm
still waiting on a [ __ ] Lego thing I
ordered from yous off Amazon going on
two [ __ ] months man they're building
a goddamn park it what what is the thing
Prime is a thing I know hey man don't
tell me I got Prime all right what else
can you tell us man without getting
fired I gotta tell you man those net gun
I imagine the last thing I can say was
Christian Bale's been at the park at
[ __ ] ton really yeah and the rumor is he
is in one of the new trilogies that's
why he's around Disney for like a ton he
might be in one of the new Star Wars
movies 3 weeks 4 visits 3 weeks 4 visits
to the park and in Nicholas Cage is
always there by the way yeah so in the
same patient buried in the parks and
they've been in the park in the same
time and they've been like opposite like
ones going the other way when this front
and they don't even notice each other
it's done with this kid it is
it's exquisite acting one of my first
memories as a kid is running into
Nicolas Cage outside of Indiana Jones
seeing the movie yeah no no outside of
the ride he shoot me off because I like
I my mom told me oh that's Nicolas Cage
and I didn't really realize like who he
exactly was so I just came up to him and
he just had like his fedora sunglasses
he was just like [ __ ] off good yeah I'm
more of a ride protector yeah
credit to Ralph all right wait did we do
a question yes cuz I know we got a lot
of fun I mean I feel like we have to
give you all the tickets because you're
about to lose your [ __ ] job give it
up for them they gotta keep recording
that podcast man and you go you look
behind me holy [ __ ] that was [ __ ] fun
who left this on the counter am I meant
to take this home
yes is for me alright what is it
yeah what is it really is that Cobra Kai
yeah [ __ ] sweet man that's kind of
[ __ ] I like to listen to I'll pop this
in give it up for him what are they
calling how do we plug them is from you
you pad Jackson
how are you pet but how do we plug these
pools is there any way to
get out of here really writer's block
ink so it's this scoot what is it
wait is that a this oh that you haven't
done it yet I'm lost hold on oh and you
got to come up here we got to hear you
otherwise nobody's gonna hear you come
on up give him a mic real quick or you
get samara tonight but go right here
against the wall so we can see you and
here you go
what's a call into the mic get it right
to your mouth unlike mark barnard a
[ __ ] writer's block incorporated
writer's block corporate does it exist
who you want it to exist every other
Tuesday in Malibu at 7:00 p.m. it's for
people who love to write and go to the
movies and you you bring us scripts
usually 20 pages at a time but if you
bring the whole script you and your
supply dinner for everybody we go
through it all in one evening with a
break for dessert that's [ __ ] cool
that's a really cool idea man
yeah all writers collective all right
past or alumni people who have shown up
include a Patrick Kilpatrick kill Jeff
rector Tom ten Aronowitz of Filmation
Fame and also Michael storage of vr
troopers anybody ever see that and I
liked so much about the comic books all
right [ __ ] that's really cool man all
right it's called writers writers and
gets in Malibu yeah writers and it's
about they meet Malby do you want do you
want other people like the general
public anybody who is into writing
screenplays you're more than welcome
just to call an RSVP and will tell you
how to get there and how do they call in
ours
should I read this over a number of the
ones before the call for details yep
three one oh four five four oh nine
seven one that's it beautiful man well
done give it up for also in there in
that boxes the GTA presents the Warriors
everywhere play that the video game
based on the movie well even if you're
not very good at I think you'll enjoy
watching it play cuz I always have so as
long as Paltrow's head is not in that
box I appreciate all these guys
give it up for my job hold on back
pleasure my friend I was going for the
handshake but yes I thought high-five
well [ __ ] man once again we've come to
that [ __ ] point of the evening where
we're out of content and stuff it's time
to go home y'all have a good time ladies
and Jonah I continue to love doing this
show and we don't get to do the show
without the thinker standing right next
to me give it up for the greats mark
Bernard and ladies it's wrong and it
certainly helps to have some place to
stand and do that and we don't have any
place without GC give it up for the scum
and villainy Cantina and of course the
good folks at 4dx who gave us tickets to
give it out the good folks at solo must
die the musical which is playing here in
town thank you for giving us tickets
thanks to everybody for showing up
tonight that is fat man I'm Batman for
this week I'm Kevin Smith - our new tune
the next time same bat-time same
bat-channel smog s.com or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Applause]
you